[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes al programa
semanal de France 24 sobre el Éxodo los
saluda Juliette riaño
[Música]
con la muerte de Hugo Chávez los últimos
10 años en Venezuela cambiaron su
historia impulsados por una inflación
galopante la escasez generalizada y la
polarización social y política millones
de personas cruzaron las fronteras de su
país con el anhelo de encontrar una vida
mejor las consecuencias miles de
familias separadas millones de historias
sobre una migración sin precedentes en
la región y otros tantos testimonios de
quienes aspiran volver algunos de ellos
a continuación
estas imágenes dan cuenta del Éxodo de
venezolanos por el paso más peligroso de
América para el tránsito de migrantes
solo durante el 2022 al menos 150.000
venezolanos cruzaron el tapón del Darién
en su ruta hacia Estados Unidos
una tendencia que se agudizó desde hace
10 años y que ha llevado a más de 7
millones de venezolanos a abandonar su
país
permiso ahí por favor países de América
Latina y el Caribe acogen a la mayoría
Colombia es el principal receptor
hasta Bogotá llegó Ángel y allí sostiene
a su familia gracias a las tradicionales
arepas y empanadas venezolanas al
principio cuando llegamos traímos algo
de dinero para pagar por lo menos media
arriendo y ya de ahí empezamos a
trabajar con las empanadas y ahí
empezamos a trabajar empezamos llegando
con comprar un termo de un termo para
vender tinto una neverita Y empezamos a
trabajar y de ahí damos descansado de
trabajar tres años trabajando Cristian
hizo lo propio en Lima trabajar fue la
única opción para cambiar su realidad
lejos de una Venezuela agobiada por
múltiples crisis todavía se vive pasar
de los cambios económicos que había en
Venezuela todavía sigue una situación
bastante difícil pues porque
lo principal que es la fuente de empleo
es lo que el poder adquisitivo el sueldo
que gana no es un sueldo adecuado a la
realidad de Venezuela me entiende y por
eso a cada venezolano que se encuentra
ya
difícil no todos pero si es difícil de
por lo menos cumplir con su primera
necesidad de que es la alimentación y
Aunque lejos en esta casa en Miami un
cuadro revela el anhelo de Lorena pero
sus palabras dan cuenta de un no retorno
la vida Que yo dejé en Venezuela hace 7
años es totalmente diferente a lo que
estoy haciendo acá
quizás hubiera estado muy frustrada Y es
que tú en mi país le des a la gente los
ojos y se le ve la desesperanza no
tienen sueños Ellos están pensando en
mañana pero no en el mañana entonces yo
soy una persona que me gusta planificar
me gusta llevar objetivos a futuro un
futuro que la mamá de Ali no ve para él
y por eso lo impulsó a dejar Venezuela
motivación que en realidad yo tuve de mi
mamá fue que ella siempre me decía y
gozar sal de Venezuela como sea
sal porque
tú no sabes que te pueda pasar el día de
mañana a pesar de que tú no hagas nada
malo en la calle a pesar de que tú estés
trabajando a pesar de que tú hagas todo
no sabe que pueda pasar mañana
y ella fue la que me motiva como te dije
no no quería salir de Venezuela no
quería
ella fue la que más me impulsó a salir
pero otros se quedaron muchas familias
no pudieron emigrar completas a pesar de
tenerlo en sus planes algunos abuelos
esperan mesadas y otros una llamada de
sus seres queridos para saber si
llegaron a destino
pero aunque emigrar fue la decisión de
muchos otros permanecieron en Venezuela
y algunos optaron por el retorno los que
permanecen viven con las múltiples
consecuencias de un país en crisis y con
sus familias lejos de casa
diez años después la imagen de Hugo
Chávez sigue presente en las calles de
Caracas
una década en la que cambiaron muchas
cosas y millones se fueron
pero en la que otros decidieron quedarse
como César
trabajando de esto pero tengo para allá
de mi familia
supuestamente la comida puede ser que lo
más importante y bueno poco a poco ya
avanzando así
lo que hay que tener fe y seguir
adelante el trabajo en Venezuela ya no
es el mismo y a José Francisco zapatero
desde hace 46 años la emigración lo
afecta directamente se han ido mucho y
me han dejado un cantidad de zapatos me
han dejado cantidad de zapatos Antier yo
bueno regalé siete sacos de zapatos
usados siete sacos uno consuela otro
porque se van y Se olvidaron de los
zapatos y aunque la familia esté fuera
para personas como luz Mila sus lugares
Venezuela Yo tengo mi familia aquí tengo
a mi mamá Tengo a mis nietos afuera pero
no no me iría a pasar trabajo
aquí a esta edad que yo tengo nadie me
va a dar trabajo pienso yo entonces
Prefiero pasar trabajo aquí que siempre
no estoy pasando porque sea como sea
sobrevivo para la comida para un par de
zapatos duro pero sobrevivo y gracias a
Dios que aquí todavía tenemos clientes
no como antes pero tenemos en la
práctica la vida ya no es la misma y
Nicolás Maduro continua dividiendo los
ánimos Y aunque exalta el espíritu
emprendedor de los que se quedaron una
migración sin precedentes marca sus 10
años frente al palacio de Miraflores
para Venezuela la última fue una década
de cambios y lo que trajo consigo es
considerada como una de las mayores
crisis de desplazamiento en el mundo
hasta que migrantes de France 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrante f24
sigan conectados con más información en
France 24 y 24.com
[Música]